bien edouard molinaro bienvenus sorte de
cinéaste culte vous êtes habillé en père
vous a fait rêver j'ai essayé de me
faire un look mais c'est bien votre look
c'est bien alors bon le coup de chapeau
à molinaro festival du film de paris
alessandra martinez vous avez été voir
son film encore ou pas la mort de belle
alors sedin oui alors au générique qui a
signé le scénario
le scénario et les dialogues c'est jean
anouilh
sinon abonnés dont anouilh fans en a
c'est pas mal bon alors vous vous êtes
combien de films en quarante ans de
métier c'est pas fini non mais
j'espérais s'est déjà tourné ensemble
tous les deux les entreprises et vous on
attend mais ça va ça va ça va ça ma
sfere sûrement vous avez pas répondu à
ma question combien de films 35 films et
autant de films pour la télévision et se
dérange pas de travailler pour la
télévision parce que les moyens sont
moindres quand même à vous c'est à dire
qu'il faut faire des petits sacrifices
sur le salaire oui et puis sur le temps
de tournage mais ça c'est une très bonne
école et puis surtout on peut y traiter
des sujets que quelquefois le cinéma
vous refuse alors bon dans ce métier
vous êtes particulier vous avez fait des
films noirs vous avez fait des films
fantasque des films satiriques
vous avez quand même une prédilection
pour la comédie j'ai fait beaucoup de
comédies en début de carrière
en fait je suis pas un acteur de comédie
j'ai beaucoup de mal surtout avec le
vaudeville
je préfère les personnages qui sont
qu'un tout petit peu de tout petit peu
de chair mais récemment j'ai pas fait de
votre vie ah oui en ce moment vous
devenez très sérieux le souper
beaumarchés à la maison que c'est un
nouveau molinaro carré louis et oui
c'est une espèce d'honorabilité tardif
comme cela je vais revenir à la comédie
j'allais revenir alors vous avez tourné
avec de funès avec ventura mais vous
dites souvent ma plus belle rencontre
c'est brel oui brel oui c était un
aspect du coup de foudre je l'admiré
comme comédien et puissions c'est
surtout l'homme qui m'a impressionné
alors s'il y avait un film dans sur les
35 films que vous avez pu réaliser un
film
maintenant que vous aimeriez refaire 35
nous vous l'avons vous êtes à ce point
satisfait ah oui oui j'ai horreur de
revoir ce que j'ai fait je n'y vois que
les défauts oui j'ai entendu parler d'un
projet avec le doc christian spitz non
non ça c'est ça s'est fait chier tourné
pour la télévision
ça c'est fait ça c'est sans voix ça
c'est fait c'est fait je vais adapter
une pièce de
scotto il s'appelle le mal de mer mer
avant une mère avec line renaud avec
edouard baer assez bien avec l'eau doyon
surfer le gil en plus de succès que des
chèques ou plus d'échecs que de succès
on doit y avoir
un tiers de succès deux tiers des
chèques à peu près